Kings opening what a surprise hmm all
right let's go with the e5 I think I
might oh man that Kings gambit is
happening whoa both your Conor gambit
let's give it a go I don't know a lot
about it at all
I know this much whoa I've never I've
played I've been playing the game a long
time we're three moves in and I have
never seen this position before okay d4
Wow we're having fun why not just play
f5 and say hey copycat land what do you
do here what I was about to say is that
if F takes a that's bad cuz it Queen
here but okay what are you doing
response to d4 Wow
c5 I thoughts typing double fault beers
you better not be listening by the way
mute that stream you can listen
afterwards these aren't being recorded
under the videos tab after the stream so
what do i do oh now that I've been
blabbing here this one just blew my hair
back here what do you do grab the pond
grab this pond I've gotten either pot
how about this guy he seems pretty good
I think I'm gonna go for that pond takes
Queen takes pawn takes Queen takes with
check or takes my queen I want to try
this one I don't know and then this one
you go on Castle Wow
show me this is one of those show me
moves you gonna take my queen no they
weren't gonna take my queen okay
look at this after all that after all
that tension in the center what we do we
say hey let's play this game without
Queens on the board and white says yeah
that is a good idea okay so the key here
is get your butt developed otherwise you
will take a beating and a half so now
what's the scoop the scoop is get castle
the King does not be well he's not
comfortable being on an open e-file is
he no he isn't this bishop is probably
excited about pinpointing this weak pun
this pawn is probably gonna want to play
here so that this Knight doesn't cause
me a headache
should I do that right now maybe maybe
not
what about what about Bishop right here
right now now White's gonna say you know
what counter-attack
not so fast okay well I'm gonna do this
and well
get my night out here I might want to
throw in b5 I've invested a lot of time
already and this is actually very 9:00
right now this night is very annoying
very annoying night okay
and with the pressure on f7 I need to do
something about that real soon
can I do something about that it's not
happening is it I can't move this rook
I think night here now let me give a
check first before this bishop place
here get out of there get out of there
and what about I'm actually gonna do
this because I'm seeing the pressure on
f7 as being too much now I know it
compromises my pawn structure but I
think that's that's the way that's a way
to alleviate the pressure white has on
the black position to say you know what
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna take a hit a
little bit where I here with the pawn
structure I'm gonna compromise that pawn
structure and then you know move forward
with like rook to d8 type of stuff maybe
even them whoa okay
black says no I'm not gonna help out
your rook I'm gonna do that and now they
have some play on this file which is
okay what do you do
you hit a knight really quick and make
that Knight make a decision make up his
mind and my opponent is flying so I need
to fly back I need to go flying to if
they're gonna fly and this is a very
sensitive point right here and I don't
want to have that exchange happen now
this SI v square is very important to me
if Knight takes Bishop I'm gonna take
with the pun and I need to I need to
shut up and play that's what this is
coming down to right now cuz my opponent
is having none of it he's having none of
it he's just saying I'm gonna fly I'm
gonna run like the wind blows and you
are going to lose on time if you don't
shut up and move your pieces so what do
you do here you go quick you stay active
you throw pig right on that second rank
and you observe a lot of pieces and
right now this rook I think got a little
bit too crazy for his own good
or did he maybe I could get this pawn
pac-man mode engaged maybe these Knights
are strung together
just keep gobbling gobbling technique
right here grab pawns and throw another
pig on the 7th put a question of this
guy now put a question just take care
take care throw a question that Bishop
get out of there Bishop and then take
this pawn hit a bishop and we'll just
keep pushing forward these guys I think
everything is nice and cozy here whoa
what am I missing
I'm not missing anything what's
happening here why is my opponent doing
that I don't have answers to these
questions I'm just gonna play here I
just want to trade a pair of rooks and
then my King is gonna be real happy with
things let's go here hit that rook and
the rooks are coming off this is plenty
of time plenty of time to do damage here
to get fast moves and okay let's get
back here King and that there's that
that rook is now
going anywhere oh this pan this pattern
this pan this pond you could call it a
pan if you want okay now let's just chop
and then push there's no stopping them
and 30 seconds is an eternity in such a
position okay good game let's back up my
opponent was going nuts right there they
were really flying let's see um let's
close out again if you're watching the
stream please don't send challenges I've
never seen this as his three moves in
here and what do you do wow I just I've
never seen d4 what's going on at d4 my
opponent said that it was what the
double fault beers is that a real thing
that's probably being silly but anyhow
my move indicates the fault B or counter
gambit but I don't know if you call this
double flop here it's really weird
it's a lot of tension in the center I
don't know how to really make sense of
it anyhow I was okay with going in for
this if my opponent really wanted to get
me on castled and try and take advantage
of that they're gonna have to have some
calculation done right to make sure that
pun is taken back so the ladies come off
development takes a very high priority
if the EE files are opened since our
Kings are on them and I throw in a check
here I don't know if I'm standing better
here I think I think just play a little
bit slower I think there's good moves
you could be making here where are the
better moves the knight move well this
is a serious threat getting into c5 so I
do need to defend against that you take
the bishop away I don't know about
taking my bishop how about you let it
sit a little bit you take the rooks yeah
this idea I don't know that that's good
the rook swinging over here if you're
looking for an attack against the king
I think that's a case of maybe being a
bit too optimistic there isn't any
attack against my king if there's some
attack it would have to involve these
three pieces and I have one which is a
good defender and he's he's reliable
like if you ever you ever get rid of
them somehow I have this guy in place to
defend them or even Knight f8 stuff so
maybe maybe this is just the the wrong
idea like instead of pointing out hey
don't do this move instead of this will
this move well I think it's more of a
case of don't run with this particular
idea if your idea is to try and attack
my King I don't think that there's
really an attack there so I think going
in a different direction then is gonna
be best maybe right now you just need to
take my rope and just say hey there's
not gonna be anything over against this
King I get way too active I can throw a
pig on the second he's hitting
everything pawns fall and then the pawns
become past and that's the that's the
ball game
was there something before this I
thought the knight move was good maybe
you could also just consider taking my
bishop take this guy and then maybe try
and pinpoint him that's another way you
could be going all right
so okay let me close out just throwing
some quick points out there for those
who are here listening